then you get
three more like feeds
messaging 13 to 22. the amount of people
that you snap to text is extraordinary
but to consume content people are not
doing that to the level that I think
snap has permission to play yeah no I
agree with you that Spotlight stuff is I
mean I think it's more on the come up
now than it's ever been yeah
vaynernation how are you I'm excited
about this episode I think we're gonna
be able to double click into a very
creative and strategic brain
um I'm gonna let Cody introduce himself
and give you all some context and I'm
gonna poke and prod on some Curiosities
I have and uh I think this is gonna be a
pretty important uh podcast for a lot of
people and you'll see why in a minute
it's a subject matter I talk a lot about
which is
things like 30 years ago nobody would
believe that he is doing what he's doing
for a living you know parents we were
taught like some of this stuff was not
good and it ends up being the best and
that has happened over time it's
happening right now with AI everyone's
scared it's and it's bad it's gonna be
the best in a lot of ways and you'll
have some bad and like everything
there's some good and bad but Cody
appreciate you being on the show brother
of course thank you for having me so
tell everyone a little bit about like
who you are and what you do yeah so I'm
Cody Conrad also known as clicks I've
been uh you know performer for fortnite
competitive professionally also
entertainer ever since I was 14. I kind
of got in the industry when I was 14.
blew up qualified for World Cup also
known you know Buddha won World Cup I
quality five times competed in World Cup
um and honestly just been playing
competitive since then now I'm 18. I'm
also a Entertainer and I do all that
stuff so so take us back even prior to
14. so just to recap real quick just
just make sure everyone contextualize
that clicks is one of the Great
professional gamers in the space 14 to
18 he's last four years has been really
doing his thing in fortnite and others
we'll go into the minute but
um the entertain end Entertainer part is
like what I want to double click into
because
uh pun intended
um
take me back further so when I want to
break down both the gaming and the
entertainment part when
prior to 14 did you have a sense that
you were good at gaming
yes so I started playing video games
Call of Duty when I was like five years
old I was like sneak in my brother's
room I had like a whole documentary I
would sneak my brother's room play Call
of Duty and like I was like as a
five-year-old that was pretty good right
I was five yes and um years coming up I
kept on playing Call of Duty gone to CS
go yeah to Minecraft it's like around 10
years old yep and um I was watching the
phase guys you know New York house and
all that so looking up to them I was
like I want to be that when I'm like 18
and 17 all that yes and you know where I
am now so um fortnite got announced
instantly played though my brother the
first game I ever played I won or my
brother this was back in probably 12
years old
um and it was 16 to compete so I was
like all right I'm just doing this for
fun but I got really good and then when
they announced World Cup they said 13
year olds uh could compete right I
actually was 13 at the time so that got
announced
um I competed where are you living at
this point in your life with my dad in
Connecticut yeah with my dad in
Connecticut so uh qualified does dad
like know that you're good at this point
does he have I don't even tell all right
I didn't say that story as well well so
to make you know to get a computer I
signed a contract with my dad to if he
got me a computer I would have to pay
him back within like like four months
either work with him or pay him back in
general and I paid him back I think it
was like 1500 and three weeks I think
just off of me doing my stuff when I was
13. meaning YouTube videos I got
honestly just want to be wanting you
know it's it's illegal now but in fact
back then one morning competing for
money yeah yeah yeah competing for money
and all that way better than my concept
of YouTube ads
so pops was pops was focused on teaching
you the right thing the value of money
of like hey you're not gonna be handed
stuff you got to earn it yeah have you
started to realize that was like a great
thing for him to do for you yeah well
now like sure of course sometimes [__]
that other people just
I just need it but you know now it
taught me all that stuff
pops is in the background I'm like
looking at him the whole time because I
love that story because that's I mean
everyone listening to the podcast knows
what I think about the pandemic that is
entitlement I think there are very few
parents unfortunately even though yeah
well Scott and I grew up in an era where
that was like the norm parents weren't
just giving kids money we [__] all
did [__] so but he's executing that to
the Next Generation that's pretty
powerful go ahead brother well for all
the Baby Boomers
um their parents always fear the things
they couldn't understand of course so
what I wanted to do is break the cycle
you know growing up in an Italian German
family it's like you know I want him to
break so that's when Cody came along and
I said you know he's really enjoying
this he's really enjoying this wouldn't
you want to have a son that really
enjoys what he's doing having a lot of
fun playing with kids all over the
United States all over the world you
have a sense that there was like real
I already hit your radar like there are
there are pro Gamers this is like a
business or that wasn't on your radar
yet yeah no clue you had no clue I
remember those days he's like oh you can
make money off of video games
Scott don't rewrite history in this
[__] podcast I didn't have a clue but
this is what we did uh you know I would
watch on you know like I said in the
mini documentary that we have
um I would go in his room and I would
watch him only for about two weeks for
about 10 15 minutes check all my emails
watch them play fortnite that's what I
did and he turned and looked at me he
says Dad Dad if you buy me this really
good gaming computer at Best Buy I'll
get so good you'd be so proud of me I'll
make so much money
and I says listen let me think about
this I says right now you know you know
the funds aren't there but let me think
about this and I'll be back in your room
in 45 minutes okay back in 45 minutes
this is what I'm gonna do I'm going to
write up a contract I'm a business guy I
said I'm going to run up a contract what
I like about it Scott is you you so many
parents overreacted to the past and to
your point you didn't want to close it
down but on the flip side you didn't go
to the extreme and just hand it you
created you kind of got the best of the
old and new world I love it all right
yep so then you just got the new
computer and what immediately obviously
you had it leveled up the whole search
yeah so got the new computer qualified
for World Cup week two which was
guaranteed fifty thousand dollars for uh
solos and I think duels was first and
then I qualified for solos also which
was another fifty thousand dollars
guaranteed if I were to go to New York
um I went to New York to compete I did
bad in Duos yeah but I didn't okay and
silos I won like 160 grand total and you
were 13 I think 14 at this point yeah 14
and I was also uh assigned to a gaming
org yeah yeah Misfits yeah and so like
so it just became very real real fast
right yeah it became very real yeah I
was gonna say real quick uh in two weeks
he made a thousand thirty five dollars
online I said he must be pretty good at
the same business sense and then I said
well then your next step
is you got to get picked from work yeah
of course I signed up at 14 years old
making fifteen hundred dollars a month
yeah that's a guy says man there's
something really yeah it's awesome talk
to me about the entertainment you know
it's funny I know a lot of Gamers
professional Gamers people in this space
people that look the profile of you know
the phase crew well know a lot of
characters you've always been pretty
consistent it's one of the things that
really hit our radar of Vayner sports
like this concept like and even it was I
was listening carefully you come out
here like okay but Entertainer talk to
me about what that is and was that
happening before even gaming like did
you see did I become an Entertainer or
how do you define being an Entertainer
or right or even more fun for all the
kids that are listening and the parents
are listening why are you saying that
and what do you mean like where are we
where are you going
so how did it become an Entertainer
basically since I was I just think it's
better right because most fortnite
players they just don't really have like
the personality to entertain people live
on stream yeah so I guess like I was
like a toxic when I was younger I was
really toxic right I was like that toxic
little kid who was like [__] talking
everybody I played against and that was
like their entertainment right yep so
like as I progress you find you know I
found new entertainment yeah where it's
like I know how to non-stop talk to
little kids non-stop like entertain kids
yeah of course and like people's
attention yeah keep their attention
which most players you know don't really
playing they just play You're
multitasking or I mean like I resonate
with that because I do a lot of public
speaking I'm public speaking like doing
my keynote right and equally paying
attention to the audience to keep them
on track yeah and adjusting even the
content potentially based on the way
they're reacting throughout exactly
that's kind of same thing with streaming
like what the chat is saying seeing if
they're bored of course change combos
get them back attached of course so
you're saying I'm an entertainer from
the standpoint of trying to educate
people like hey I'm not just good at
playing the game exactly I'm also
bringing another variable to the table
and what you're doing is you're
educating the masses because as you know
Aaron I was like I I'm aware there's
certain players who are just locked in
and they're just it's almost like Andre
Agassi versus Pete Sampras right if you
use a tennis comp you know Pete Sampras
was just like straight down the line
vanilla piece of paper but he was an
epic tennis player and Agassi was an
epic tennis player right that people
came out to see because he was
entertaining right right so I'll be like
basically getting like 20 bombs while
entertaining the chat so it's kind of
it's a correlation with what you're
trying to say yep and so now what what
are you thinking about right now so now
you know I just signed to Vayner yep um
I'm still doing the normal stuff still
competing a lot kind of like my schedule
now I just moved to Dallas for a
competition so I'm competing but I'm
also when comp isn't going on I'm doing
like entertaining stuff entertaining
streams like I just stream in La you you
might have seen it basically like two
girls caused a lot of drama but you know
the dramas is entertainment for the
other people you know how do you find
the balance of
to keep it in that kind of middle you
know I think about the world right now
it's so political red blue and I'm
always like how is it purple so that
it's like you know like that you find
that middle do you think about that like
when you're thinking about doing
entertainment that's going to be
interesting for people are you trying to
find a fine line where it's not at the
detriment of other like it's probably a
tough thing to juggle well I think I
just do what I think is going to be like
funny I guess and I don't like let it
get you know too chaotic unless the
girls make it at that chaotic and
sometimes that does happen you're not in
control of other people but if that
happens it's not me and it's
entertainment for other people and it's
you know in my head like I'm like yo
like this is [__] hilarious but like
in like their mind it's like a real life
like interaction but I'm just like
trying to make it entertaining and the
chat's going crazy it's three in the
morning it was it was a blast But like
after on Tick Tock it was like 30
million views in like two days on my
channels yeah just off of like posting
eclipse and then like Bryce Hall and
Josh had him on their Tick Tock and like
BFFs podcast and it was like good
entertainment but in my end I I'm just
[__] around when they're being free
yeah I mean it's so interesting I think
a lot about where the world's at in in
at this point and like not giving kids
the freedom to like live youthful energy
is like a super challenge like when me
and my friends and everybody who's
listening who's 35 45 55 65 75 when we
were goofin when we were 15 to 18 it was
just lost in The Ether right but now
when you guys are goofing uh it's just
documented yeah it's a very different
mindset that's the beauty of this
industry you can do whatever and you
make you know people entertain you also
make money off of doing what you want to
do of course Andrew Dice Clay was
entertaining people thought it was like
you remember that era like that was like
whoa like too hard in 1988 now that's
mundane tick tocks the world just
continues to evolve are you thinking
about business how do you know pops
talking in the background about business
guy so you've got some of that DNA like
how how do you think about business like
how do you think about what are deals
that are right for you Ambitions right
things you want to do in your 20s 30s
40s 50s 60s I mean right now I'm not
really you know obviously you have to be
focused on the business part that's why
you know a son of a Vayner yep um but
back then feldy he still is my manager
he was you know getting all the deals
yes I mainly just do the full
entertainment stuff and kind of let the
background people do the deals and like
the numbers that I feel are right for a
deal kind of like
something you know I'm saying like he
knows what's going on right you trust
the people yeah I trust the people
around what you're focused on is unless
you like completely hate the product or
yeah it's corny You'll Play in that
exactly exactly but you trust the people
to understand the business exactly I'm
focused on the entertainment they're
focusing on ideas and what's good for my
brand and what's not good and so very
simply I'm sorry
to do of course
90 of the time you've got that locked in
right yep yep
and
and then it's like if you want to do
anything outside like start a brand new
all that stuff like let's do it and
let's just get
yeah yeah I mean I think I think for all
the people that are listening that
manage talent I always say like if
you're going to be great at it you're
going to have 90 of it figured out like
90 of time you're gonna be like he's
gonna do it he's not gonna do it she's
gonna do it she's not gonna do it what
you have to be is make sure that you
don't have ego as a manager or someone
that reps and think you're 100 right you
have to have the humility to be like you
know what pretty sure he's not going to
want to do this but I'm going to put it
in front of him
in front of her and let them decide and
I think that's like when those
Partnerships go best right they're
saving you Time by not bringing you
stuff but he's also got the humility
we've got the humility to put stuff in
front of you where we're not exactly
sure and plus your temperament changes
especially when you're young I think the
most interesting part about I see it in
all of our facets gaming sports I see it
in all of marketing see it in influencer
marketing we all know this we've lived
it a lot of you are living it a lot of
you are now in this room and listening
in the 20 30 40 year old Range man who
you are at 15 versus who you are at 17
versus who you are at 19. versus who you
are at 23 and 27 you're like different
humans in such quick windows and that's
also something that needs to be on
strategy of what you will and won't
where are your Ambitions on the
non-entertaining part meaning
do you as an athlete as like a player as
a skill
are you overly
crazy about getting better are you
chilling on that like the game you're
saying and then like even think like let
me let me ask the direct question I'm
curious about has it run through your
mind that there'll be another game right
right a Call of Duty a four night that
comes out in the next 24 36 months that
captures the gaming world's attention
will you have a lot of thirst so let's
play it out two years from now you're
making more money there's more good
stuff happening you're more famous do
you intuitively feel that you're gonna
put your head down like 14 15 year old
you and have the bandwidth and the time
to be great or do you think you like
every other athlete like we see this in
all other sports you like were obsessed
to get to be 17 and the best tennis
player in the world and then you're
super famous and doing cool [__] and all
of a sudden it's hard because there's
some kid from Yugoslavia that's 13
that's doing this like what's your like
do you feel the 13 year olds and 14 year
olds who do nothing but [__] try to
get great like what's your sense I mean
in two years I don't think I would want
to play another game like fortnite's
like kind of like my hot spot you know
what I'm saying like I'm good at that
game yes I'm a professional player I'm
Gonna Keep on doing that yes until the
game runs out yes I'm not gonna let
myself get bad but I'm also gonna be
doing the entertainment spot on the side
just in case God forbid fortnite dies I
still have that entertainment aspect to
go on about I don't think I would ever
play another game which really what
you're trying to say is like my 13 year
old self would want to go pro in any
game right like now it's like I've been
a pro for four years
I'm gonna be 20 if the game dies might
as well you know take like an acting
route or something like I'm already
doing entertainment you know I got you I
got you me getting the acting job that
was the exact question and I think
that's super interesting I think there's
like clearly like two three paths there
I get it right but it's interesting
though right the Cs go natural Talent
was able and work like translated to
some degree to fortnite right do you
feel like the skill that you have at
fortnite could translate to lasers and
lightning if that became the thing I
think a hundred I mean I think games
genetics I'm gonna be honest I've been
playing since I was like five years old
so that has a lot to go into it but like
bro I have good news basketball's
genetics tennis is genetics
like someone can't practice 10 hours a
day I'm practicing 10 hours a day and
somehow you know yeah yeah exactly
exactly so it's like what I want to
become a professional I don't really
know I get it it would have to be a
perfect scenario for me to you know go
back putting 10 hours a day into that
while you know if I'm streaming it and
the game's blowing up and everything's
going good and I'm becoming professional
will bring value to the audience
um social networks right your current
take on like the best apps and the not
best apps oh that's a good one good best
apps in my opinion yep Twitter yep oh
this is hard Twitter Twitter 100 you
know I'm on the app all the time okay
Instagram I think is terrible now I
think you know what they did with the
whole entire like paying for like views
and I hate the verified aspect you know
like what are your thoughts on that yeah
to be very Frank for me it's like
Logistics now that everyone has a
verified account it doesn't let me
quickly and I see if there's an account
like that's verified that I might need
to be intrigued by or look at so like
it's made it lost I love it as a
business model I oh I mean I have videos
that I'm I need the team to dig up six
seven years ago I'm like these social
networks are gonna figure this out and
charge 10 bucks a month because it's
just good business yeah it made sense I
mean yeah they're making a bank off and
doing it but I guess you know I get it
yep go ahead I mean in Instagram in
general I'm pretty sure now it's like to
get on a bigger like when you post it
doesn't actually pop up on the feed no
until unless you pay for it no no
still like you can still plenty people
are getting there problem with Instagram
is organic reaches down because so much
attention has gone to tick tock during a
time where more con more content is
being produced on Instagram than ever
but the attention's not at the height
that it was because there's an enormous
amount of under 35 that now has given a
ton of its attention to shorts and Tick
Tock so this is shy in demand all right
keep going so that's Instagram sit down
on that a little bit what about Shorts
YouTube shorts I think are amazing I
recently started like shorts and you
know they a whole another Channel
they've been killing it shorts are crazy
Tick Tock I think is amazing yep like
definitely the best way to promote
anything that you have going on do you
think that if the US Bans
and like burn houses down
I don't think that's gonna happen I just
I can't see a world where they're
actually in a band how many careers you
think would fall off of like that in
general so many people use like Tick
Tock for business in general to like
make more money for like wouldn't they
just go to Instagram and YouTube won't
be the same though I know that so I
think you are right I think it would
promote no but dude like do you think 17
year olds are gonna burn their school
down kind of thing
I think it would be a little bit younger
than that I think a little bit like 14
13.
uh LinkedIn does that even hit your like
are you like what the [__] are you
talking about Gary I don't even know
what you just said uh I was like I
totally get it
um talk to me about
snap Snapchat
I don't use Snapchat no no I'm verified
on it not even the message I know you're
mad at that I'm not I don't give a [__]
oh you don't give a [__] oh yeah we'll
talk about it all right I don't use tick
shock that much nap has the biggest
outside
growth if they just got spotlight
like then you get to get to get light in
stories more like the
because they've got you know this
messaging they own right like 13 to 22
like 30 snap the amount of people that
you snap to text is extraordinary but to
consume content people are not doing
that right to the level that I think
snap has permission to play yeah no I
agree with you that Spotlight stuff is I
mean I think it's more on the come up
now than it's ever been yeah but you
know I don't I don't post anything
Facebook
dude I haven't download that app in my
whole life never downloaded feedback no
that was always like your dad's thing
yeah I feel like it's older generation
thing 100 anything else do you know what
Clapper is huh Clapper no seriously it's
like a complete clone of tick tock that
I think is
like sitting in the cut and if they're
like if Tick Tock gets banned we may
explode anything out what about I mean
twitch is a different thing
I think it's massive I mean what are
your thoughts on the recent stuff going
on I mean like some of the things that
people can and can't do like kick coming
out now you know they're cutting half 36
of their whole entire company yeah I
mean I think that's just natural
Ness but I don't think that you I don't
think you as a Creator feel any effects
of that reality companies are worried
about their stock price so they do
things but I don't think you're going to
feel the there's still plenty of people
that are doing [__] to me I'm platform
agnostic if twitch and Tick Tock
Facebook LinkedIn YouTube disappeared
tomorrow banned
banned
I'm like okay like I gotta go be better
at Twitter and whatever's left like
people are gonna go wherever they're
gonna go right like like it's the same
argument I have with TV and connect the
TV and streaming services like
like all these companies wasting money
on running commercials on regular TV
when everyone's attention's on social
exactly I agree with that and and that's
why I think uh influencers and
entertainers like yourself will continue
to get market share because you have now
built up enough awareness that you're
agnostic if YouTube and and Twitter and
twitch go away or kick like you have the
ability to literally the next day
because everyone you have to understand
it it's fan for everyone right it's not
like you got banned from it's banned
from everything so everybody's gonna go
to another yeah what are they gonna read
newspapers yeah you just new things form
and so I think that's always going on
what about from you from a content
creator standpoint who do you think is
doing a good job
right now yeah or even historically like
things that you've looked at that you're
like oh that person like things they do
and not even maybe like what entertains
you maybe people that have you've
learned from I mean face-to-face Clan
yeah that was back then you know they're
going through a lot right now but of
course I mean I think you know kai sinat
he's a great example of like doing the
impossible like nobody ever thought
someone could get 300 000
um subscribers while you know
entertaining a hundred thousand people
at once non-stop you know he was 24 7
live stream for 30 days and seeing like
him his mom calling him hitting a
hundred thousand Subs was like
inspirational for me you know even
though I I'm also doing good as well but
like of course different step of like
your parents calling you crying and
being like wow like I was you know he's
doing it different that's a good example
that like I want to become where after
fortnite do like the entertainment
aspect what he's doing you know it's so
funny you say that
I want a lot of parents to hear like a
lot of these kids are doing the same
things that you grew up with you always
hear about stand-up comics saying things
like in documentaries like a Chris Rock
or Dave Chappelle will be like but when
Eddie Murphy did raw I knew that I had
to go up another step or when like
players today like talk about like when
Allen Iverson was that quick I knew that
I like I just wish people knew how much
being a streaming Entertainer or a gamer
was a talent and a skill that has
requires incredible amounts of work and
to Pops your point putting a bow on this
whole combo the parents that are most
open to I mean like literally every
parent that has an 11 year old right now
84 of them are telling their parents
they want to be an influencer a Creator
a YouTuber a gamer and you know for many
parents they struggle with believing
that can be true and it's only going to
be more true five years from now 10
years from now because it's become like
normal it's become like a normal sport
brother that green book right there the
black crush it I wrote that in 2009 how
old were you in 2009 four good when you
were four when I wrote that so if you
read that book the hypothesis is like
this YouTube thing is new and I think
people are going to make a living on it
if you go to Amazon and look at the
first reviews of that book that I wrote
in 2009 everyone's reviews of my book
were like one star you're full of [__]
what do you [__] talk nobody's gonna
make a hundred thousand dollars a year
on YouTube think about how outlandish
that is now there's people who do that
in a day yeah today so I the world's
going to continue to move it needs
people like you showing the way and I
appreciate you doing that I appreciate
you for having me thanks for being on of
course
awesome cool good stuff good stuff